The great Jackie Robinson accomplished an
amazing amount in his lifetime both on and
off the field.
Despite all the adversity and pressure he
experienced, he somehow managed to put up
legitimate Hall of Fame numbers doing what
is often described as the hardest thing in
all of sports- hitting a round ball with a
thin round stick.
One thing that he didn’t do, something that’s
often credited to him, was become the first
African American person to play in the Major
Leagues.
That was something that had been done at least
three times before Robinson made his historic
Major League debut on April 15, 1947.
Now if you happen to be a trivia buff and
knew that already, odds are you think the
first was actually Moses Fleetwood Walker,
the second was his brother Weldy Walker, and
you’re probably scratching your head trying
to come up with the third.
It turns out, that’s probably not correct
either, although the verdict is still slightly
out on the matter (being a very recent discovery).
The real first African American to play in
the major leagues, and the only former slave
to do so, is now generally thought to be a
man by the name of William Edward White.
Eighteen year old White, who at the time was
a student at Brown, replaced an injured Joe
Start in one single game in the Majors, playing
for the National League Providence Grays on
June 21, 1879.
This was five years before Fleetwood Walker
would make his Major League debut.
In that game, White went 1 for 4 and scored
a run in a game the Grays won 5 to 3.
While not a lot is known about White, what
is known is that he officially claimed he
himself was “white” and not of African
heritage (his skin color apparently being
light enough to pass as such).
This is why up until very recently he wasn’t
given credit for being the first African American
to play in the Majors, with that honor going
to Moses Fleetwood Walker.
This all changed when members of the Society
for American Baseball Research, more commonly
known as “SABR”, uncovered the fact that,
according to an 1870 U.S. census, White’s
mother was a woman named Hannah White, one
of the 70 slaves owned by the person William
White listed as his father according to Brown
University’s records- Andrew Jackson White.
Hannah’s other two children also appear
to have been fathered by Andrew Jackson White.
A.J.
White also left the bulk of his estate to
Hannah’s three children when he died, including
William White, though he only acknowledged
them as “the children of my servant Hannah”,
rather than his own children.
In the context of solving the mystery of whether
William White was the first African American
to play in the Majors, the important bit in
the Will is that he named William the child
of Hannah, which backs up what the U.S. census
stated.
Thus, with the evidence at hand so far, it
appears William White was the first African
American to play in the Majors.
As to why he never played again after that
game, it isn’t known, but of course speculation
is that his heritage was discovered, though
it may have simply been that a better player
was in the wings, as his replacement was future
Hall of Famer Jim O’Rourke.
Whatever the case, the person long considered
to have been the first African American to
play in the Majors was, as mentioned, Moses
Fleetwood Walker.
Walker made his Major League debut on May
1, 1884 playing for the Toledo Blue Stockings
against the Louisville Eclipse.
He had been playing for the then minor league
Blue Stockings when the team was added to
the American Association, which later became
the American League.
By all accounts, Walker was no less of an
amazing player than the great Jackie Robinson,
and is deserving of a lot of credit for what
he went through during his time in the Majors.
How good was he?
Let’s just qualify the stats with the fact
that Walker was a catcher… who caught without
a glove or any other major protection, as
was common at the time.
Needless to say, catchers of the day were
incredibly injury prone and rarely did well
offensively because of the beating they took
behind the plate.
Walker had it worse than most because many
of the pitchers didn’t want to let a black
man ostensibly tell them what to do by calling
the pitches.
As one pitcher, Tony Mullane, stated:
[Walker] was the best catcher I ever worked
with, but I disliked [the] Negro and whenever
I had to pitch to him I used to pitch anything
I wanted without looking at his signals.
As a result, Walker was in the unenviable
position of crouching behind the plate attempting
to catch baseballs with no protective gear
nor glove and not knowing the location nor
what pitch was going to be thrown.
Despite this, in his 42 games played in the
Majors, he batted .263 (some accounts claim
.264).
Now that might not sound impressive, but you
should consider the fact that this was well
above average in his day- the rest of his
team combined for an average of just .231
with the league average just .240 the season
he played.
Further, as catchers took an incredible beating
(and still do today, though to a drastically
lesser extent), most catchers typically batted
between .100-.200 in his day.
He was so good with his bat, that when he
was too beat up to catch, they’d typically
put him in the outfield so as not to lose
his offensive production.
He also had to overcome the same type of obstacles
as Jackie Robinson, including death threats,
constant personal and physical attacks, and
certain players refusing to play if Walker
was allowed on the field, such as future Hall
of Famer Adrian “Cap” Anson (the first
major leaguer to accumulate more than 3,000
hits, finishing with 3,481).
In fact, Fleetwood Walker’s brother, Weldy
Walker, who also played in the Majors (5 games),
blamed Anson for the banning of African American
players in the Minor and Major leagues in
the first place.
(In truth, Anson’s despicable antics probably
didn’t have nearly that much to do with
it, though Anson was quite vocal about his
opinions on the matter and not shy at all
about trying to pressure others into advocating
for the same stance.)
For instance, in Anson’s first encounter
with Walker, Walker was supposed to have the
day off, but when manager Charlie Morton heard
that Anson and his team, the White Stockings,
were refusing to play if Walker was allowed
on the field, he put Walker in the lineup
and told Anson that not only would they be
forfeiting the game if they refused to play,
but they’d also forfeit the money from ticket
sales.
Once money was brought into it, Anson and
the White Stockings begrudgingly agreed to
play.
After being injured to the point where he
couldn’t bat, Fleetwood Walker’s Major
League career ended up being over.
Once he was healed up, he continued his career
in the minors (which in 1887 boasted 13 African
Americans despite rampant segregation).
He also played in a few other leagues before
finally both the National League and the American
Association decided on their “gentleman’s
agreement” to not sign any African American
player, with that decision trickling down
to other leagues that had not already instituted
similar bans.
Robbed of the ability to play in the American
and National Leagues as well as most others
of any note at the time, Fleetwood Walker
left baseball, as his brother also later did
after playing and managing in a Negro league
that ultimately failed.
The two went on to various business ventures,
at which they were seemingly quite successful,
such as owning an operating a hotel, a movie
theater, as well as a series of restaurants.
Fleetwood Walker even attempted to get patents
on a few different pieces of equipment he
invented for showing “moving pictures”;
he also held a patent for a certain type of
exploding artillery shell.
The two also became involved in politics with
Weldy Walker serving on the Executive Committee
of the Negro Protective Party, which was formed
in response to the government turning a blind
eye on the frequent lynchings that occurred
at the time.
The two also owned and operated the newspaper,
The Equator.
I’ll close this with an excerpt from an
open letter from Weldy Walker to the President
of the Tri-State League published in The Sporting
Life on March 14, 1888, after African Americans
were officially banned from playing in those
leagues when a law permitting them to be signed
was repealed by the league:
…It is not because I was reserved and have
been denied making my bread and butter with
some club that I speak; but it is in hopes
that the action taken at your last meeting
will be called up for reconsideration at your
next.
The law is disgrace to the present age, and
reflects very much upon the intelligence of
your last meeting, and casts derision at the
laws of Ohio- the voice of the people- that
say all men are equal.
I would suggest that your honorable body,
in case that black law is not repealed, pass
one making it criminal for a colored man or
woman to be found in a ball ground.
There is now the same accommodation made for
the colored patron of the game as the white,
and the same provision and dispensation is
made of the money of them both that finds
its way into the coffers of the various clubs.
There should be some broader cause–such
as want of ability, behavior, and intelligence–for
barring a player than his color.
It is for these reasons and because I think
ability and intelligence should be recognized
first and last–at all times and by everyone–I
ask the question again, why was the “law
permitting colored men to sign repealed, etc.?”
Yours truly, Weldy W. Walker
While on the whole the Walker brothers did
quite well for themselves financially in their
lives after baseball, particularly considering
the racial obstacles they had to deal with
at the time, Fleetwood Walker was once attacked
by a group of white men.
During the ensuing melee, Walker killed one
of the men, Patrick Murray.
The remaining attackers attempted to kill
Walker, but he escaped, though was later arrested
and imprisoned.
Somewhat surprisingly given attitudes at the
time, on June 3, 1891 at the conclusion of
his trial, a jury of all white men acquitted
Walker
on all charges.